[Music]  it actually is torture what she went  through  as a child to call it abuse is really to  not  capture how horrific her upbringing was  people have to understand that children  that go through  childhood abuse it changes  who they are i went through that and it  took me years and years  to overcome it but i also had a good  foundation that helped me overcome it  lisa did not have that foundation and  she was broken  [Music]  it is not about getting her out of  prison it's not about excusing  um the crime it's about you know  explaining  why it is that this is a situation where  president trump  should exercise mercy mrs montgomery  is the only person who has committed  this sort of crime  to be facing execution and that is  because  other prosecutors recognize that women  who  commit these crimes typically have a  very serious  history of mental illness and trauma as  lisa does  [Music]  oh  you